Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott are  getting flirty mister rollercoaster of  emotions  Stormy's parents were spotted spending  time together at a casino over the  holiday weekend and an ET source has  confirmed they spent Thanksgiving at  kris Jenner's home in Palm Springs ET  exclusively learned from a source close  to the couple that they were also being  quote flirty I'm in a very weird  position because I care so much about my  family the news comes less than two  months after the pair announced their  split in October but their relationship  status has not changed the source tells  ET quote the couple has always been on  good terms and stormy is their main  priority  adding although the duo is spending time  together and have been flirty they're  not back together  I don't feel any different but it's the  source adds quote to everyone around  them is hopeful we will work it out  [Music]